hello and welcome to this announcement  video which looks a little bit different  because I'm recording this from my  vacation spot in Slovenia I'm going to  be online nevertheless at this I'm going  to try and see how good the connection  is from this place it should work but  you know no I think it will work out we  will start relatively early today 5 p.m.  Central European Time because of the  simple cup so we don't want to collide  with that so we solid 5 with the German  show in 90 minutes later 6:30 Central  Europe in time we're going to switch to  the English show which also lasts 90  minutes the links are in the description  I hope you will be able to make it  thanks a lot - till then bye bye